à ouistreham les touristes britanniques
ont filé à l'anglais en temps normal les
9000 habitants de cette petite ville des
côtes normandes vivent au rythme des
ferries chaque année près d'un million
de passagers effectue la liaison entre
cette station balnéaire et la ville
anglaise de portsmouth sur ces navires
de la compagnie brittany ferries des
passagers qui pour la plupart ne
débarqueront plus à ouistreham du moins
pas avant que le royaume uni ne lève la
14ème imposées depuis le 15 août à tous
les voyageurs en provenance de france un
manque à gagner pour les hôtels de la
ville
à ouistreham la clientèle britannique
représente une part non négligeable de
leur chiffre d'affaires
alors forcément olivier ô mon patron du
normandie accuse le coup ces derniers
jours qu'il a vu son établissement se
vider progressivement on compte beaucoup
sur septembre et octobre sont des mois
for homes un taux d'occupation
équivalent au mois de juillet en sachant
que ben pour l'instant on n'a plus de
réservations la saison démarre à 8
samedi de pâques jusqu'au premier
n'auront donc juste deux ans
durant cette période la jeunesse ils
seront présents on a décrit la clientèle
habituée anglaise qui viennent
régulièrement qu'on n'a pas eu cette
année
du côté de la restauration la situation
n'est guère plus enviable
cet établissement situé à deux pas de
l'embarcadère devra compter sans les
clients anglais soit 30% de l'affluence
saisonnière c'est un coup assez assez
dur en plus du coït qui s'ajoute à ce
qu'assure que cette année on a beaucoup
moins de clients étrangers et un peu
plus de france est forcément on a fait
un mois de juillet assez assez difficile
mais le mois d'août est assez bon et à
fin août c'est un peu plus dur depuis
justement à 14 heures donc effectivement
on a beaucoup de clients qui viennent
manger ici avant de prendre le bateau
donc respirer un peu pour servir et donc
ouais ça fait quand même pas mal de
clients des touristes qui viennent sur
les plages du débarquement donc c'est
quand même une perte assez
assez majeur l'hôtellerie et la
restauration ne sont pas les seul
secteur à pâtir de la décision
britannique 35 mille passagers de la
brittany ferries ont d'ores et déjà à
annuler ou reporter leur voyage
ce mercredi la compagnie a annoncé une
réduction du nombre de ses navires
effectuant la liaison entre l'île et le
continent
trois d'entre eux resteront à quai soit
un tiers de la flotte et une partie des
effectifs sera mis au chômage partiel
est derrière moi la manche et à moins de
200 kilomètres les côtes anglaises et
les touristes britanniques qui sont
rentrés chez eux sur ce navire que vous
voyez au loin derrière moi un coup dur
pour l'économie de ouistreham sans
compter les américains adeptes du
tourisme mémoriel très développé dans la
région qui manque aussi à l'appel
alors selon certains professionnels les
vacanciers français compensant en partie
ce manque à gagner
mais ils redoutent des jours très
difficiles à compter du début de
l'automne